but now everybody gets married for love
and love fluctuates but you can get
married for a clout
you're so true you also used to have the
families involved very much so and so
like fathers would vet the people that
their daughters were seeing now it's
like girls will go after the guy that
like feels feels good it feels good but
that's not usually the best husband and
guys will do the same thing guys will go
off to a girl that an IG Baddie yeah
that looks great and you know what her
whole attitude is ridiculous and she
doesn't know how to be a mother she
doesn't know how to be a cook she
doesn't have to clean she doesn't have
to do all of the things that you would
expect from the duties that you would
expect from a wife so yeah I just think
yeah the the institution is outdated
because I think human beings in the west
generally have outgrown the essentials
of what marriage is